alright let's get started a lot to talk
about today first stream of the week
last stream of the week I don't know I
don't know but there is a lot to talk
about all our little graphics and stuff
it's all working pretty well now we've
got latest contributions through either
stream labs or super chat and when
people actually make a contribution
let's see if I can trigger one of these
it'll look like this there we go that's
what it would look like if i donated $36
to myself so anyway you can check that
out Stream labs comm slash the david
pakman show and super chat and all that
stuff but more on that later I'm going
to talk about some of the changes
upcoming to the David Pakman show
and some of the changes we've already
sort of toyed around with I'm going to
talk about some of the latest
geopolitical news I will answer
questions I will talk about tomorrow's
program I will sort of run a few ideas
by you also that I've been thinking of
for the program for new features and
other things so really a lot to talk
about a lot to talk about and I want to
welcome everybody if this is your first
live stream this is different than the
video clips that we upload to YouTube
from our national talk radio and
television program this is just a live
stream we are just hanging out and the
good news is that you can participate
you can use super chat that's the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window in
order to send questions or comments you
can also now circumvent YouTube taking
30% of our super chat revenue by making
the contributions at stream labs.com
slash the david pakman show and those
will also come up on screen they will
also come up up here and you can still
submit a question or make a comment and
I will read it and react as always any
new members and patrons who sign up or
pledge during the live stream will get a
shout out and thank you from me and I
will sing your praises we're starting
the evening at 1900
25 patrons and it would be great to get
to 1940 let's just throw out that if we
get to 1940 today I will create a huge
membership discount code and I won't
tell anybody but you because you're on
the stream ok that's if we get to 1940
patrons we're starting at 1925 and
lastly please don't troll no trolling
obvious trolling is going to get you
banned we do have moderators seeing what
it is that happens in the Chad and by
all means feel free to subtly troll but
please no obvious trolling because
that's a major major distraction ok
let's talk about changes to the David
Pakman show we've been experimenting the
David Pakman show has always sort of
been an iterative endeavor right there's
no final format of the show I know that
the the I've interviewed people who use
the term final form and they mean
something very different from what I'm
talking about but it's sort of a
constant evolution of the show and there
was actually a point where we used to do
things we used to basically do nine
stories plus an interview per show we
would do three stories in the first
segment and three stories in the second
segment and then we would do the
interview in segment three and then we
would do two more stories plus play and
react to an audience voicemail in the
last of four segments of the show and
there's been a general people don't
usually complain about the general
format of the show I mean it generally
appeals to people that's why they're
watching the program but the one comment
that did keep coming up was David it
would be great if you could go more in
depth with stories so over the last 12
to 18 months or so we've gone from this
sort of three three three format of
three sex stories in each of our non
interview segments on the show more to
two three three right going from three
to two stories in that first segment of
the show and fleshing those stories out
a little more
and recently I've actually been toying
with doing as few as one story in the
first segment going from three to two
stories in the second segment and then
also from three to two stories in the
last segment and what this week this has
gotten us is more like a ten twelve or
even 15 minute first story at the top of
the show where we can go into a lot more
detail now for the most part people seem
to like this most of the comments I've
gotten are that that's that's a good
change I've not really heard any
complaints from people saying I'd rather
you gloss over more of the details and
it's not really disrupting the interview
it's not really disrupting everything
else we're doing we're just less able to
do the quick run-through a bunch of the
sort of notes of the day right the Trump
approval rating is down three points or
it's up or whatever if we talk about
Trump approval rating it's in some kind
of more in-depth and broader analysis
like like what we did today my instinct
is that people are liking this and we do
still have the opportunity we still have
the space and the bandwidth to do more
of those shorter political stories in
the bonus show and I know yeah the bonus
shows only for paid members etc but
we're making more bonus shows available
for free we are now making two bonus
shows a month available for free to
everybody instead of one bonus show a
month part of it is just marketing the
membership program but part of it is if
we're gonna do more political stories on
the bonus show you might as well make
them available to more people so this is
sort of the direction we're going and
I'm interested in hearing feedback if
you want to comment on that either
through super chat or through stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show I
would be interested to hear what people
think and it's always tough because it's
a there's serious self selection bias in
terms of who we hear from on the format
of the show most people who watch the
show or listen to the show we have never
heard from and we will never hear from
right because most people do not
interact in any way with the shows that
they watch or listen to you I have never
sent an email or tried to communicate
with any of the news shows that I watch
so I'm aware that the vast majority
majority of the
we will never hear from and that's just
sort of a reality we have to live with
but I'm encouraging you let me know what
you think do you want fewer stories more
in depth each day do you want running
through more stories do you want
different things all together let me
know and we we I mean the whole point
we're the program is financially
supported by the audience so it sort of
makes sense that from a general
perspective we tailor the show in terms
of its structure to what it is that
interests people some upcoming things
that are going on related to the show
show or surrounding the show number one
I am teaching this class as an adjunct
professor at Boston College here in the
Boston area and I've gotten a bunch of
requests from people to film the classes
and upload them to youtube and I think
that's a really interesting idea being
that this is my first time doing this
and that I don't want to number one this
is not the first time you teach in a new
course is not going to be the best time
that you teach that new course you're
going to teach it better when it's not
new so if I were to film the Boston
College lectures I'd rather do it if I
am lucky enough to be invited to teach
the class again but in addition to that
I think that there's an opportunity and
I'm curious I want to run this idea by
you would it be interesting to recreate
some of those lectures in other words
take my it's a very long class but
there's about an hour to an hour and
fifteen minute lecture portion with
class participation what if I recreated
that with my PowerPoint slides and and
really went into depth on some of these
media literacy and critical thinking and
journalism issues in a four youtube
format right so it would not be filming
in the class but I would sort of redo
that lecture I don't know what the
visuals exactly would be would it would
I be in a split screen with the slides
would we be cutting back and forth I
don't know so if that sounds interesting
to you but please get in touch let me
know make yourselves heard if that
potentially this would be a sort of
patreon or membership benefit right that
would be an interesting thing to look at
doing these long lecture
as a bonus content type of thing and
also there's the possibility of maybe
getting somebody from the audience who
says hey I can edit this together for
you I would like to work on this with
you what if you record just narration
and then the visuals are just slides or
what if you record yourself like you're
doing right now
send me the slides and then I will cut
it together in an interesting way if
that sounds like something that's a way
that some people always email me and say
David how could you get that how could
you get how could I get involved with
the show in some way I'd like to
volunteer my time this is a way this is
something we could work together on if
you have the skills to sort of make this
happen in an interesting way we're all
ready for classes in right I already
have four seventy five minute lectures
that we could reformat and repurpose and
put up on YouTube maybe there would be
one free one and then the rest are a
patreon benefit at the five-dollar level
or the two dollar level or whatever I'm
interested and and of course you know
the it's not the reason why I'm looking
for new stuff to offer you is because we
need to for financial reasons right the
the reality is we're basically not
making money on YouTube anymore I heard
today from my YouTube contact sort of my
YouTube partner manager and I was asked
how are things going and I said this is
how things are going you have access to
our revenue things are not going well
and I'm basically at a point where I
need to just figure out new revenue
sources we can't count on YouTube the
way we used to be able to for revenue so
that's where this idea for the lectures
is coming from in addition to this I'm
also increasingly being invited to speak
at colleges and universities and I've
got a couple of these gigs already
booked for this current semester we're
starting to look at gigs for the spring
semester so two-fold opportunity there
number one if you are involved with any
college club group or organization or
department that might want to have me
there let's talk about that get in touch
but also that's another opportunity
where that's something that I could look
at having filmed and maybe make that
available on YouTube maybe to premium
subscribers at david pakman.com slash
membership maybe we make that available
at the $5 patreon
or the $2 patreon level or whatever so
so also things that are that that are
going on so that is what is coming up
and things I am thinking about and of
course we are very closely following
number one how the patreon supporter
base is going we're up to 1925 patrons
I'd like to get to 2000 as soon as
possible and when we do that I've
committed to doing an entire show from
our broadcast studio with my hair
uncontrolled and I've spoken to some
folks at the FCC and they they're not
aware of any legal problems with me not
not controlling my hair but on a sort of
personal no they did say you sure you
want to do this it could be bad but I've
committed to doing it when we get to
2,000 patrons and I will stick to that
we started the evening at 1925 patrons
but thanks to the generous $5 pledge
from grace wire we are now at 1926 and
1940 is the target for the evening and
lastly I'm going to jump into some some
more meaty politic stuff in a second new
members will also be thanked when they
sign up Paul ward has just become a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership and I do want to thank Paul
for becoming a member you can do the
same thing at david pakman.com slash
membership and if you want a 40%
discount you can do that by entering the
coupon code
I voted 17 on the second page of the
sign up more thank-yous upcoming ok
alright let me talk politics a little
bit some things that are on my mind and
then we'll start getting into super
chats and donations that are coming in
and all of that other very very exciting
stuff so we did a story today on the
Regular Show and it was titled something
along the lines of Trump threatens
genocide at UN speech turned campaign
rally and this is of course related to
Donald Trump saying that if Rocketman
his new name for kim jeong-hoon
Catman doesn't back off or if you know
he does whatever it is Trump doesn't
want him to do that the US will have no
choice but to quote totally destroy
North Korea now I've already received
some flak there's people who like to
just go through just about every YouTube
video I do and leave comments like for
example clickbait
this is clickbait or this is fake news
and they said that the use of the word
genocide was a form of clickbait or fake
news first of all if you if you think
it's fake news you have no idea what
fake news is right you've been
completely bamboozled by Trump's usage
of the term I believe it is perfectly
accurate to say that Donald Trump was
threatening genocide when he said we
will totally destroy North Korea totally
destroying North Korea would be the mass
killing of a significant portion of the
North Korean population and Donald Trump
did not say we would have to remove kim
jeong-hoon from power
he didn't say military action would have
to be done he said we will have no
choice but to totally destroy North
Korea and when you are President of the
United States and everyone knows the
military firepower that the United
States has even before the additional
700 billion that has recently been
authorized by Republicans and Democrats
in the Senate even without that it's a
credible threat when the President of
the United States says we will have no
choice but to completely destroy North
Korea so if if your biggest criticism of
my piece about Donald Trump's
embarrassing pathetic and disturbing and
downright dangerous speech at the UN is
using the term genocide in the title is
clickbait you've already lost what now
is popular among so-called classical
liberals the war of ideas we hear so
much from different elements of the
political spectrum that we need to be
engaging in a war of ideas and not
shutting down
and not using at homonyms or logically
fallacious arguments saying that my
argument is invalid because the word
genocide is clickbait is not exactly
debating the merits of what Donald Trump
said right and not debating the
specifics so I think that the reason
we're seeing these types of logically
fallacious arguments against progressive
YouTube channels and programs like the
david pakman show is that the trumpian
right knows if only subconsciously I
want to sort of qualify it that way they
know that it's not going well they have
to on some level realize that Donald
Trump is not having the great success of
making America great again that he
campaigned on and that it's actually
quite an international embarrassment so
when you can only criticize a quite
extensive analysis that I've done about
this issue by saying the title is
clickbait and we've dealt with this
before if you've been following the
program for a while you know we've dealt
with this before you're already losing
the argument so make an actual case for
why threatening the total destruction of
North Korea
is not effectively genocide and then
we'll have that conversation if you want
to make that argument be a super chat or
via stream labs.com slash the david
pakman show or whatever the else else
the case may be by all means do it and
we'll debate it on its merits okay okay
let's look at we've got one super chat
in so far and it's from cold war 45 who
sent the $10 super chat thanks very much
cold war make some things exclusive to
patreon and some things exclusive to
membership that way you can incentivize
people that do want to do both yeah you
know this is I I mean I don't even know
if this is the right venue to talk about
this stuff but there is there is sort of
a difficulty with the do we make the
patreon and membership benefits the same
or do we make them different and and the
difficulty is I don't want to
cannibalize membership with patreon or
patreon with membership right and that
is one reason why we
would make the benefits totally
different we would say here is the set
of benefits you get if you become a
member
here's a set of benefits you get if
you're a patreon donor and if they're
different benefits then you might do
both if you like the benefits of both
the concern is it's really important to
keep things simple and not because
people are stupid but merely because
people have lives and I don't want to
even make it so that people have to sit
down and say okay let's see I like the
David Pakman show and I think supporting
media that you that you value
financially is important let me now
evaluate what are the membership
benefits and what are the patreon
benefits and how do they compare and
what are the price levels and and and
which one's a better value that's why so
far if you remember you get the bonus
show you get invited to the Members Only
Live streams you get the full commercial
free show and all that stuff and on
patreon at the two five and ten dollar
levels you've got the exact same
benefits available so just so that
people do whatever it is that's
comfortable for them right if you
already have a patreon account it might
be easier to just add us to the maybe
eight ten or twelve shows you're already
supporting on patreon rather than making
an account on our website right so this
is sort of the logic of why we're doing
it the way that we are doing it so that
that's the explanation there cold war 45
we do also have a contribution via
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show from christina who made a dollar
contribution weighing in on the
possibility of turning my Boston College
lectures into long-form premium content
for you guys
Christina says would love the lecture
recreations I hope you enjoyed doing
these live streams as much as I enjoy
watching I do like the live streams I do
like the live streams and you know as
the show has grown one thing that I have
prioritized and that I think is very
very important is not to and thanks
Dylan for that contribution and thanks
for the contributor under the name of
Newton Pakman I think it's important not
to sort of lose contact with the
audience and we now get
generally we get about 1500 YouTube
comments a day unless I made reviewing
YouTube comments my full-time job I
couldn't possibly keep up with every
single comment we get hundreds of emails
per day dozens and dozens of tweets and
Facebook messages and it does become
difficult and this is a great problem to
have for a show it becomes difficult to
keep up with every message so I like
doing the live streams to get a sense of
what it is the time on the audience's
mind and continue to iterate and improve
the program for people who have ideas
and have feedback Dylan has sent a $5
super chat love your show and would love
to take your class at Boston College any
advice on thinking clearly not allowing
emotion to cloud your reasoning well
that it's a very deep that that could be
answered in a very in-depth way but I
think that if you establish a good sort
of epistemology and critical thinking
base you can react to all assertions in
the same way and that's I think the best
idea to take at least an initial
emotional response away if you hear an
idea that aligns with your pre-existing
views and if you hear an idea that
doesn't align with your pre-existing
views the best thing you can immediately
do is no matter what your your gut
reaction is say wait a second how do I
know if that's true and on what sort of
a pistola logical basis am i saying
here's what I believe and if you can
approach every assertion in that way and
it doesn't have to be a really formal
thing it just has to be do I agree with
that or don't I and why that's a good
initial basis to really think about why
it is that you believe what you believe
and I think that that it's a good start
and III delve into that a lot when I do
lectures on critical thinking and
epistemology and particularly media
literacy okay let's see what is next
here I want to try to go in the order
that these comments and questions are
coming in so next is I believe the user
who made a contribution at stream labs
comm slash the David
Hockman show under the name 'not on
Pakman who is of course is my brother in
the former TV director of the David
Pakman show who actually flies into
Boston tonight / tomorrow on a red-eye
so he will be visiting he might be
stopping by David Pakman show studios
and maybe offering some technical advice
about what's going on at the studio so
very very exciting things this is of
course not really nat on but it is I
think our regular contributor on the
live streams who likes to ask questions
in Spanish and indeed that is what this
user did and I will read it in Spanish
and then translate for you como estas
Corrado a viendo tu hermano live comme
moi see uh-oh these are clearly Google
Translate translations because they are
insanely awkward Portuguese sunless
super chats in espanol tan mucho ciao
mamma cuando tienes tiempo te quiero
eeka buta natin okay yeah so this this
is now a completely outrageous super
chat and these are translated to Spanish
from English they don't make any sense
the initial question is how are you
going on to say how strange it is to see
your money live like this but it was
again translated in a completely
nonsensical way why are the Spanish
Spanish super super chats so much much I
mean there's no translating this it
doesn't make any sense
call me when you have time I love you
you son of a [ __ ] in a time okay so you
got me to speak Spanish congratulations
appreciate the contribution cold-war 45
has sent a $5 super check did you hear
the latest Manafort news according to
the Washington Post he offered to give a
Russian billionaire private briefings on
the 26:16 campaign I did not hear that
let me take a look at my multi reddit
that let's see Moeller looking for White
House documents related to Trump actions
as president Russians appear to use
Facebook to push Trump rallies in 17 US
cities I am not seeing that let me go
right to the wash
in post and see if I can take a look at
that headline because that is very very
interesting man afford offered private
briefings on 2016 race to an ally of
Vladimir Putin since we're going to talk
about this and I appreciate you bringing
this up I will just paste this link into
the description here for the live stream
and you can check it out there ok let's
see what this Washington Post article is
alleging less than two weeks before
Donald Trump accepted the Republican
nomination his campaign chairman offered
to provide briefings on the race to a
Russian billionaire closely aligned with
the Kremlin according to people familiar
with the discussions Paul Manafort made
the offer in an email here we go to an
overseas intermediary asking that a
message be sent to Oleg Deripaska
there's a name we've heard before an
aluminum magnate with whom anna fort had
done business in the past these people
said manna fort wrote in the july 7th
2016 email if he needs private briefings
we can accommodate the emails are among
tens of thousands of documents that have
been turned over to congressional
investigators and special counsel Robert
Mulder's team as they probe whether
Trump Associates coordinated with Russia
as part of the effort to help Donald
Trump win that is a major story and its
major because if anybody is going down
first other than Michael Flynn there is
every indication there is every
indication that it is Paul Manafort and
we talked yesterday and I'm bookmarking
this story now for tomorrow's show we
talked yesterday about how multiple
individuals familiar with the
investigation into Paul manna for its
doing we can't call it necessarily
wrongdoing have said that an indictment
is imminent against Paul Manafort and
that is major
that is absolutely major and all of the
chips seem to be being put on the table
so to speak here and this is it's going
to get really interesting
can anyone say at this point that the
story about Russia is going away and
I've been
I've been making an effort I've been
trying to control myself and not cover
Russia every day but it's it's sort of
crazy to be ignoring it at this point it
really is a very interesting story 21st
century mouse has sent a five Canadian
dollar super chat it's hard to tell
who's serious and who's not on the
alt-right but some are how do you decide
when to debate or not waste time by
feeding trolls I try to I try to decide
when to debate when I believe that there
is actually an argument worth debating
right so ad homonyms are not worth
debating you you know trolling
repetitions of debunk talking points are
rarely worth debating but if there's an
argument that seems to be having an
impact and be taken seriously by some
significant portion of a population then
that's something that we can debate and
and maybe attempt to debunk right I
think that that that's a good at least
initial standard hunter Ragland sending
a $2 super chat what is your opinion on
Justin Bieber I think that Justin Bieber
is a scourge of the music world I truly
do and I say this in two ways I say this
number one because someone recently
shared on Facebook you know how now
Facebook videos seem to autoplay at full
volume someone shared one of Justin
Bieber singing at a recent concert
couldn't seem like the guy could sing I
I don't
I'm not familiar with the ebbs and flows
of Justin Bieber's career I couldn't
tell I couldn't name a single Justin
Bieber album but I know that at one
point maybe it was pre puberty I don't
know the guy seemed to be able to sing
okay it was basically Justin Bieber
singing over a track and sometimes he
wouldn't even sing for 30 seconds at a
time during the song and I said people
pay for this people are paying for this
nonsense
but yeah so anyway hunter my opinion of
Justin Bieber is not particularly high
Chris utt sig has sent a $2 super chat
any plans to have Daniel Kahneman on for
an interview I'm glad you asked this I
recently recommended Daniel Kahneman's
book Thinking Fast and Slow and
immediately after recommending it I did
reach out to Daniel Kahneman about an
interview he did get back to me he
indicated yeah I don't know what's
public about Daniel Kahneman so I don't
want I don't want to say anything that I
shouldn't be saying but he indicated
that there were personal circumstances
that made it so that he did not feel
that he had the time to commit to an
interview at that time and I respected
that but he was very very gracious and
we exchanged a couple of emails and I
Daniel Kahneman has an open invitation
to come on the program absolutely
anytime that he wants anytime Daniel
Kahneman wants to be on the program he
is more than welcome to be on Christina
has sent a dollar contribution through
stream labs.com slash the David Pakman
show
Christina said do you prefer low-key
weekends at home maybe cooking a blue
apron meal or to fill your free time
with activities my weekends are pretty
busy Christina I don't know when the
last weekend was that I wasn't either
out of town or busy and I don't know
when the next one will be this weekend
I'm out of town and the following
weekend well I guess that last weekend
in September might be my next low-key
weekend but typically the weekends are
pretty hectic and and there's a lot of
work on the weekends I know that we do
the show five days a week but there's
really no way to do the five day a week
show without doing quite a bit of other
stuff on weekends including more general
background research on issues and a lot
of different stuff right so if it's a
look loke weekend's mean work weekends
that's sort of the reality ceci Canales
has sent the twenty five dollar super
chat do you think the graham Cassidy
version of krump care will pass in the
Senate sorry if you've already talked
about this peace be with you I I've sort
of I did a breakdown
it was either yesterday or the day
before I think it was I don't know
it was sometime this week of this new
version of Trump care that has been
proposed and I do believe it has a
really solid chance of passing in the
Senate and not because all of a sudden
it's this wonderful bill that
Republicans can get behind but rather
because Republicans are trying to pass
it by September 30th and before
September 30th they would be able to
pass this with only 50% plus one votes
in favor
and after September 30th they would need
60 votes so I actually am genuinely
afraid that this new version of the bill
which ironically enough and and calling
it irony I think calling it irony is
maybe not not the right word this would
be the worst version right this this is
the worst version potentially 32 million
people will lose coverage as a result of
I guess we're calling this Trump Care
3.0 I don't know what we want to call
this one the Trump one point Trump care
1.0 and 2.0 failed miserably it actually
may pass and it's it's time now right
who is my representative calm you can
look up exactly who your representatives
are and call every single one of them
anybody who will take a phone call
you should call because this actually
might pass and it will be absolutely and
totally disastrous Tony Merritt has sent
a 10 British pound super Chad what do
you think the realistic chances are of
war with North Korea until recently I
thought they were pretty small but I'm
getting the sense Trump and many
Republicans seem intent on it
III think there's a real possibility of
a conflict an armed conflict with North
Korea I'm not saying I want it but I'm
also not saying that they wouldn't
deserve it right III think that we have
a very belligerent country in North
Korea no one can deny that I question
whether the best path forward will that
would actually be military action if
you've heard this before I apologize for
doing this again but some people haven't
heard this I actually believe that there
is a potentially better diplomatic
option than sanctions and potentially
more effective option
than an armed conflict with North Korea
which is I get why if you're Kim jong-un
you want to develop nuclear weapons
I say let's consider giving North Korea
treating North Korea like an adult and
saying hey we want to talk to you about
establishing and okaying a nuclear
research program for you but if you want
to be treated like an adult if you want
to be treated like a like the other
countries that do research of this kind
then you need to play by the rules
that means you agree to limit research
and development as agreed upon by
international committee consensus you
agree to allow in inspectors you can't
threaten other countries with use of
nuclear weapons you you want a seat at
the table here's an opportunity and I've
read some pretty interesting analyses
from foreign policy experts who say this
is barely getting a mention but it
really is worth considering so I think
that that is something that Trump would
would likely never do Trump wants to
keep being belligerent about Rocketman
and all this other stuff but I think
it's something that would absolutely be
worth considering okay let me do some
thank-yous we started the evening at
1925 patreon contributors I put out
there that if we can get to 1940 patreon
contributors by the end of the night I
would create and release just for you
won't tweet it won't post it to
Instagram won't post it to Twitter won't
post it anywhere else but I will
announce it on the live stream a huge
coupon code off of membership okay so
the target is 1940 we had one
contribution right at the beginning of
the live stream we have two more one
from Ash mystery who just pledged two
dollars a month ash Thank You ash is an
incredible person and we need the
contributions at any level even at $2 a
month even at $1 a month and I want to
thank a sh for making that kind
I also want to thank Matias fields
Matias fields has made a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show of
five dollars a month five dollars a
month that gets us to nineteen twenty
eight we are now at 1928 patrons the
target for the evening is nineteen forty
help us get there help me get to 1940
and we will then create and release a
forty percent I'm sorry a fifty five
percent discount code for membership
speaking of membership I do want to say
thank you to Jean Johnson Jean Johnson
has signed up for a membership at david
pakman.com slash membership i also want
to say thank you to veronica Catalina I
like that name Veronica Catalina has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership and jenny geyser jenny geyser
or maybe it's guesser has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership all
really great people listen we've got a
situation here
where there is a sort of concerted
effort being made Trump talking about
let's make it easier to sue media
outlets Trump talking about demand that
media outlets always use named sources
we've got an FCC that is trying to roll
back the net neutrality Internet freedom
provisions that were enacted under
President Obama which would make it
easier for big media to make it more
difficult for small media like us to
communicate with you by allowing for
internet fast lanes and signup and slow
lanes by not categorizing Internet
service providers as common carriers and
really thinking of the internet as a
basic utility which it really is at this
point who can who can deny that and
there is also a concerted effort through
the YouTube ad YouTube ad boycott or D
monetization to make it seem as though
it's just too crazy to advertise on
YouTube and you should rather put your
money in if you are a big advertiser
into legacy media rather than YouTube
where programs like ours would have
access to a little slice right so it's
not a great situation out there that's
why I'm looking
extra content I can create for you that
might incentivize you to become a member
or page with patron that's why I'm
running by running ideas by you like I
did at the beginning of the livestream
about creating a long-form versions of
my Boston College lectures from the
class I'm teaching and making them
available to our paid subscribers and
patreon subscribers all the stuff is I'd
rather just be hosting the show but
we've got to do it because of the
financial situation so the thank-yous
will keep coming and I appreciate
everybody who's contributed so far ok
we've got a couple other contributions
and super chats that I want to mention
uh-oh rocky cook has made a $3 and sixty
eight cent contribution with the message
g'day from New Zealand thank you it must
be what 8:30 8 in the morning on
Thursday September 21st there thanks for
waking up with David Pakman show
livestream show time 8 D 7 has sent a
nine dollar and twenty cent super chat
how big of an issue in day-to-day life
is political correctness Fox News and
youtubers make it seem as though lefties
are triggered by everything listen I am
not afraid of calling out oppressive
political correctness when it exists but
it doesn't exist that much and you will
see you know there's there's a cottage
industry out there it's kind of sad
right I mean I'm here trying to do a
public service by informing as best I
can
our audience on important issues and
doing a breakdown of what would the
economic impact of the $15 minimum wage
be what would the detailed impact of
Trump Care 3.0 be and we are of course
trying to self-fund
and there's this cottage industry of
pointing to individual instances of what
exists in the same way that it exists on
the right you also see instances of
trying to limit conversation by the left
and creating the sky is falling
perspective of it's impossible now to
have debate political correctness is
crazy you can't talk about anything
on campus you can't talk about anything
in the media you can't send a memo out
it work James d'amour I'm talking about
without getting fired if it's anything
but the approved progressive line these
things exist and there's more than
enough of them to do a show around but
there's also more than enough instances
of you know I don't I don't know white
supremacist violence that you could do a
show around that and it wouldn't
represent the true scope of that problem
in society so it's very profitable to go
around talking about political
correctness as the problem and all of
this other stuff but I do think that it
is dishonest and in the sense that it
blows up and disproportionately sort of
makes it seem like a drastically bigger
issue than it actually is if you want me
to dig into that in more detail I'm glad
to Maria Romero has sent a $5 super chat
I sent the contribution through stream
labs I'm not sure if you received it it
did not pop up on your screen Maria we
didn't let me see I'm looking here at
the list of stream labs comm slash the
david pakman show contributions and it
didn't come through which is why it
didn't pop up on the screen okay I
appreciate the super chat Maria also
saying I love the new format of the show
thank you and again it's not it's not
really a new format it's sort of just a
tweak to the format that we've had for a
while we are just sort of stretching out
that first story on the show and
stretching out a little bit the second
and third stories on the show that show
up in the second segment and if you're
hearing me talk about the show and the
first segment and the second segment and
you have no idea what I'm talking about
because you just watch youtube clips the
David Pakman show is on nearly 200 radio
and television stations almost all of
them non-commercial stations public
radio public television I see the
broadcast of the David Pakman show on
those stations as a public service a
service to community media so we don't
make any money by being on those
stations in fact we pay
for bandwidth and server space and the
distribution and formatting and staff
time for an extra version of the show
that gets delivered just to those
stations that's done at our expense and
that's part of what when you make as
little as $1 contribution on patreon or
a membership that's part of what you're
paying for
so yes you get the bonus show and all
these other great member and patron
benefits but you're also paying for the
infrastructure and the staff
infrastructure that exists to five days
a week
deliver a show to non-commercial radio
and television stations that couldn't
even afford 50 bucks a month right these
are stations with no budget that are
typically run by volunteers that's part
of what is funded by memberships and
patreon contributions so if you see
community community media as an
important thing the patreon
contributions go directly to that
cold-war 45 has sent a five-dollar
contribution very very much appreciated
asking what do you think will ultimately
happen in Venezuela a Civil War American
intervention absolute dictatorship and
repair repression something else so when
I talk about Venezuela to be totally
honest with you we typically lose
financial support because there are some
on the Left who are so committed to the
idea of Venezuela as some kind of
progressive social democracy or or
democratic socialist paradise that when
they see me say Venezuela is a left-wing
populist charade actually covering for
authoritarian strongmen dictatorship
type government structure people get mad
people get really really mad but that's
the way I see it and I've never changed
an opinion on the program because of the
fact that people are bailing on
supporting us financially I'm not going
to start now
and that's the way I see Venezuela so
I'm being totally upfront with you
because that's the context of the answer
that I'm about to give I believe that
there are sort of two paths forward for
Venezuela Argentina my home country is
in a sort of different state Argentina
has been rife with corruption for a very
very long time but it's it's not been
the type of authoritarianism that
Venezuela is experiencing so the economy
in Argentina has been crappy for a very
very long time it's not necessarily
going to completely implode but it's not
necessarily going to get better either
in fact it could stay the way it is for
decades longer in Argentina where you've
got you know it's not the the poorest
part of Latin America but it's also not
doing particularly well corruption
continues to have a significant negative
impact in Argentina and it has for a
very long time it could sort of stay
this way for a long time I don't think
it's tenable that Venezuela will sort
just sort of stay the same way for a
very long time I think you are either
going to see a drastic change in what's
going on in Venezuela maybe through
American involvement in American
involvement in Latin in South America in
Central and South America Latin America
call it call it however you want to
delineate it it's been pretty bad so I'm
not looking forward to American
intervention in Venezuela however I am
not in the camp that says I support the
Maduro regime because the opposition is
American funded astroturf there's no
doubt that the United States has an
interest in what's going on in Venezuela
but I don't support non democracies and
that's what Venezuela is so I think that
it could go one way where the situation
implodes and you do see outside
influence that changes the status quo
you could also see a further regression
into total dictatorship it's close to it
right now it's not there exactly but you
could also see that and I genuinely
don't know
the direction that that it will go okay
I think we've got another stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show
contribution we've got a couple actually
let me do those first and then I will
get back to super chat sapper 1 sapper
11 said please invite me to your
impeachment party haha with a $15.00
contribution at stream lives comm slash
the David Pakman show
consider yourself invited we will
probably do if impeachment proceedings
begin we will probably do some kind of
wacky in studio livestream or something
it'll be it'll be a big party even
though I've actually been been pretty
upfront in my concerns about whether
impeachment at from Trump is actually
the best thing to stop the right-wing
agenda it might not be I won't redo that
little rant now but but I've talked
about that christina has sent a $5
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show contribution thank you for your
time and effort when did you know you
wanted to commit to hosting a political
commentary show do you have any regrets
my regret is not having taken it more
seriously earlier because I started the
David Pakman show when I was was it a
junior or senior at the University of
Massachusetts I believe I was a incoming
senior at the University of
Massachusetts it started as a hobby once
every other week and as I was a senior
and as I went directly into graduate
school where I got my MBA I continued
doing the show but really as a hobby and
only towards the end of my MBA program
did I realize that my classmates were
going to be financial advisors I tried
that didn't internship and financial
advising and even though I have an MBA
with a specialty in part and financial
advising I realized that's not the
direction I wanted to go consulting and
working absolutely insane hours and
banking and this is generally where my
classmates were going I knew I didn't
want to do that and so really it was in
the last semester of getting my M
that I realized let's give it a shot
really taking it seriously as a job and
fortunately it worked my regret is had I
realized that earlier the show might be
even further ahead of where it is now
but but other than that no regrets
Adrienne M has sent a $2.00 stream
labs.com slashed the david pakman show
contribution in Spanish de beat koalas
to cancion fajita in empanada the
question being David what's your
favorite song in Spanish I don't have a
favorite song in Spanish but three bands
that I really like that are that are
mostly doing music in Spanish are locked
bedico's that's an Argentinian sort of
like a reggae alternative reggae band I
saw them play here in Brighton and it's
so funny they sell out major venues in
all of Latin America particularly in
Argentina Chile Mexico for example in
the u.s. they're not that well-known and
they played at Brighton Music Hall which
is a venue that holds I would guess five
to six hundred people and it was more
than half empty it was I mean I was
standing in the front row effectively it
was standing room only
absolutely great band bedico so you can
look them up
another one is Joseph Cadillacs which is
another sort of alt rock band and there
is a third argentinian band that I
really like called los authentico they
got in this and they are more like ska I
guess I would call it ska ska punk alt I
don't even know what to call it all good
bands a lot of good videos of them on
YouTube you can check those out
Bryan Rasmussen has sent a $5 stream
labs.com slash the david pakman show
contribution when Donald Trump is
impeached will we be stuck with Mike
Pence for the remainder of the term or
will there be a special election that
Brian is part of why I am NOT one of
these people who simply thinks that
impeachment is the path forward I
because we don't know what will happen
with pen
and even if pence was complicit in
whatever it is that might ultimately
bring down Donald Trump it's not super
likely that if Trump goes Pence will go
it could happen but it might not the
best path forward for Trump for the
trumpet Enda being totally stalled and
for the Republican agenda to be totally
stalled might be for Trump to stay in
but to be crippled by controversy
scandal embarrassment on the world stage
and everything it is that we're seeing
happen right now so I think Brian you're
thinking about this in the exact right
way that's one of the reasons why I'd be
concerned about the impeachment of
Donald Trump facts night has sent a $5
super cheque do you think YouTube TV
will be a threat to your channel and
other news and politics YouTube channels
if so what will you do to prepare for it
I believe that YouTube TV is already a
threat to YouTube channels like the
David Pakman show and we are already
trying to prepare for it by moving our
business not moving the audience but
moving our business in other words
revenue off of youtube so facts if
you're not aware we have lost 90% of our
YouTube ad revenue okay
1.1 is the beginning of the year point 4
is where we are now after a little bit
of an ebb and flow starting at the very
beginning of April YouTube red is one
thing that in an effort to push people
towards YouTube red it's sort of
conspiratorial what I've gotten some
some comments from people suggesting
that we should move that in order for
youtubers to encourage their audience to
subscribe for YouTube red they've
demonetised a lot of videos because I
can say to my audience hey a way to give
me back some of the revenues if you
become a YouTube red subscribers I think
it's a little conspiratorial but I think
the more relevant possibility is what
you're talking about facts which is
YouTube TV YouTube TV and wanting to
push people there is a much more
plausible reason why D monetization
might
be going on and yeah very very good
point and on that note just a reminder
we are trying to get to 1940 patreon
contributors by the end of the
livestream if we do I will create and
release a fifty five percent discount
code for membership I will only tell you
nobody else will know just you and you
can also sign up now for membership at
david pakman.com slash membership you
drag that red dot wherever you want pick
a price and click the red sign up button
and then amazing things will happen like
you getting instant access to the bonus
show and a lot of other great member
benefits Tim crit has sent a five euro
super chat what do you think about what
is happening in Catalonia I I've been
following what's going on in Catalonia
somewhat closely Catalonia is in the
middle of well K I mean there's actually
a lot of backstory to this but Catalonia
is a region of Spain it's a region of
Spain that has had a more sort of
independent what would you call it an
independent streak and independent
desire to separate from the country of
Spain and it's quite controversial
within Spain it's controversial within
Catalonia and recently things have
really escalated Spanish police recently
raided several Catalonia nor Catalan
government agencies as well as the
telecom centre they are holding the
secretary of the economy we are also
dealing with increased unrest in the
streets in Catalonia you know I
personally don't take a position on
whether I think that they should become
independent I think that Who am I as an
American despite having a family in
Spain to say that the Catalonian people
should or shouldn't be allowed to be
independent my concern is more the way
that this has escalated that tensions
have increased drastically and now
you're seeing violence you're starting
to see oppression you're starting to see
all sorts of sketchy stuff going on so
Tim I'm considering maybe diving into
this in more detail next week on the
show and and
I don't know I know that there's a lot
of our audience that doesn't really care
for some of the they care about world
news that directly relates to the US so
what's going on in North Korea or Syria
or whatever but less interested in the
internal struggles and countries I think
it's a pretty interesting story I think
that there is a lot to that story and
you know we have the Kurdish
independence vote that is upcoming and
that does relate to many of our allies
in the United States but but may be more
of a direct connection than the
Catalonia thing but because I have
family in Spain and my stepmom is from
Spain and I've got cousins there I have
been following it and I think it's a
pretty interesting situation makeshift
altruist has sent a two dollar question
free will true or false
could you will otherwise I don't know
exactly what it is that you're asking me
are you saying does free will exist or
is everything predetermined I believe
that you can have sort of a biological
determinism point of view but still
believe that what that biological
determinism has enabled is humans to
have free will and to make decisions
freely so I am NOT a sort of a
black/white guy on the issue of free
will but I don't I genuinely am Not sure
that I understand the question
totally and if you want to clarify by
all means feel free Adrienne M has sent
a $2.00 contribution through stream
labs.com
slash the david pakman show another
question in Spanish I will read it in
Spanish in the original Spanish and then
translate it for you question is though
eat qua DiSanto pensamientos and is dim
lord the mexico so the question is my
thoughts on the earthquake that has
taken place in Mexico I think it's
absolutely horrible of course I think
it's absolutely horrible Mexico is a
country that I've spent I wouldn't say a
of time in but I've been to Mexico I
think probably five five times I believe
and is one of the most interesting
places that I visited I found the Mex
excuse me the Mexican people to be some
of the warmest people that I've ever
come across I was hoping to be able to
make it to Mexico this year it's not
going to happen unfortunately but I of
course any earthquake any tragedy of the
natural disaster kind is horrific and
there is no exception in Mexico and what
what else can we say I mean we really
cannot say much else
you know the infrastructure of a country
different countries and even within
countries different regions of countries
are differently prepared to deal with
natural disasters earthquake
preparedness hurricane preparedness all
of these different things vary in
countries it often is an economic thing
and it's absolutely horrible what
happened in Mexico cold war 45 has sent
a five dollar super chat I think cold
war 45 is officially the contribution
all star of today's livestream asking
have I seen the trouble James de
Morrison now after a tweet about cool Ku
Klux Klan titles yeah I did I saw that
James d'amour the fired Google engineer
who I interviewed earlier this week if
you did not see the full at 30 something
a minute interview with James d'amour
please check it out because I found it
pretty compelling he tweeted something
about how I'm paraphrasing here but it
was something along the lines of despite
what you think about Nazi ideology and
the KKK that Nazi uniforms and titles in
the Ku Klux Klan like being Grand Wizard
appeal to young men and that you know
whatever I think it's it's absolute and
total idiocy sure you can find young men
who like tabletop role-playing games
can't believe I'm blank Dungeons &
Dragons type games who might see the
uniforms of the Nazis or of the KKK or
the titles of the KKK as sort of
appealing in some way but for the most
part the idea of joining a hate group
that has depraved racist ideology merely
to maybe one day be called the Grand
Dragon or Grand Wizard you can always
find examples that make these assertions
anecdotally true but it's it's what why
do you feel the need to go out and make
this your issue right I mean I I truly
don't understand it it doesn't make any
sense to me okay we sadly did not make
it to 1940 patreon contributors we fell
short of actually 1930 but that's okay I
want to thank the people that did
contribute I want to thank everybody who
contributed and you can see the most
recent six contributions up here you can
contribute any time to stream lives comm
slash the david pakman show and skip the
30% cut that YouTube takes from Super
chats but more importantly I invite you
I encourage you I implore you to support
media that you believe deserves
supporting contribute as little as a
dollar a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and get similar
benefits the bonus show the
commercial-free all-access pass at Paige
I'm sorry at david pakman.com slash
membership welcome to all the new
members and patrons i will stream again
soon that I can promise you folks
believe me